so
because when we think of like the
traditional record deal right like
most artists would come off the street
take a cute as big of an advance as they
can get right but then
you know two years later they complain
they've never seen a check off of music
well it's because you've never recouped
right so when you guys went to red bull
you figured out kind of a life hack if
we go to red bull we can get so much
money within red bull that we don't have
to really ever worry about yeah and you
don't want to take a crazy advance up
front because you know like like you
said you were in a position where he was
making so much money off distro kid and
you know a lot of people go for that
first they want the bigger advance but
it's like if you don't need the advance
why do you take it it's a shitty loan
right honestly bro
it's a precedent we ought to say for
real for real because i mean
saying is deeper than rap is kind of
cliche but it's really deeper than rap
though you know cause we already just
seen the people go
be superstars but didn't have nothing at
the end
i mean meek mill just complained about
this i mean a lot of people who we look
at like not 100 a lot of our favorite
people are like aren't seeing money off
their
exactly they got to stretch that check
but which is why they didn't really be
killing themselves over doing so many
shows and being on the road so much to
see that upfront ticket sale you know
what i mean so just like i already knew
you don't want to stretch yourself out
with anything you do so however you can
create fillers in between the times that
you want to take breaks throughout
creativity okay what is the best avenue
to be able to do that so
not having to take a crazy advance but
still being able to make six figures
plus just on outside entities within the
company is like oh that's guaranteed
checks i'm gonna get just because i'm
doing business with the companies and
they best favor to make me happy and
vice versa so you know it's just i think
that uh i thought the people at red bull
when we signed i was like really pretty
much this is us being the cool kids
coming to sit with the nerds and making
the nerves popular
and i'm like but it's mutually
beneficial because the nerves you got
the answers to all the tests so i'm like
i'm not tripping off kicking in with the
nerves because i see the mutual
beneficiary part of the whole thing
also too i think you guys are in a great
position too where it's like red bull is
i'm sure their music division doesn't
have to make money
because they have so much other [ __ ]
going on yeah i mean they're standing
like a guinea pig i guess i started this
you know what i mean like it's like it's
like when we think of red bull like the
11th thing we probably think about is
the fact oh they put music out too yeah
but i mean just a note they got rock
bands going platinum i didn't know that
i didn't know that so yeah that's like
they got a band called bear tooth and
they got these girls called the aces
like they both go crazy um they sell out
crazy product crazy merchandising like
them type of deals
is like really what like entices me
because i already know but you don't
really you make pennies on a dollar on
music you feel me even if you got a very
favorable deal it's just like streams
just don't pay you that much for you to
sit there and be like i can make all my
money off that so it's like i believe in
physical product and actually you know
branching out and investing is actual
money we got going on and different [ __ ]
that's gonna make us way more money